whatever their motivation to be in the
race and it's different in every case
obviously I think some of them a base
themselves I think just to get attention
because they're trying to ink but I
think dennis kucinich is actually kind
of interesting because dennis kucinich
in the 2000 yeah Jen through Dennis
Kucinich in two thousand and maybe even
in 2004 clowned around a lot I mean to
the point that you thought is this guy
does he care about anything and I
interviewed him then and I've
interviewed him this time around and
there was no clowning around and that's
an interesting sign of the times the
French candidate is is movably serious
last time when he was single he was
willing to put himself up for a mock
dating contest on The Tonight Show and
all these different things that made you
go was he just in this for attention but
this time he's been really serious and I
think we're Bell is serious too I you
know he's a I was in one press room for
a debate where the reporters were
laughing at him so waiting for the wacky
comments he was going to make and I
actually thought that they were great
comments they helped shake the debate
out of its pre-scripted torpor and you
know and and and and you know um enliven
it and I don't mean that in a
condescending way I mean at one point he
said Hezbollah is not a terrorist
organization because I guess Hezbollah
like Hamas has an arm that provides
social services and the reporters
laughed at him but it was a provocative
good comment to throw in there and force
other people to respond to and if people
had followed up on it it would have if
other candidates had followed up on it
it would have made a difference and he
is saying at one point that Hezbollah is
not a terrorist organization and in fact
Hezbollah from what I understand like
Hamas has social service wings or they
also kill people but uh it's it's a
valid comment and
and you know but but they're they're
allowed to sit there like the wacky
relative that just has to be suffered
through